get ready for the main event
you better not be back with me no
photographs cause i got cataracts
i see i'm not gonna get the bachelorette
party i waxed for
i love it a black lady sketch show is
back and so is ashley nicole black
welcome hi thanks for having me well
first of all congrats on season three
three seasons thank you how are you
feeling about it you guys feel like you
really hit your stride now oh man you
know as a comedian you have your little
bag of tricks your little characters
that you play when you get to season
three you're like
i've played all the characters i'm gonna
play you're gonna see some wild stuff on
this season i had to go to eleven and
see that's what i'm curious about like
when you know where do you get a lot of
the inspiration for these characters and
for these sketches are you got trader
joe's just like observing people like
i'm gonna remember that for sure also
like my friends and family there's a
character i played last season ally who
like hypes everybody up and i was
waiting for my friend who that was based
on to text me and be like is this me
come on green dress oh thanks allie come
on brand new red shoes
appreciate you girl nordstroms okay come
through fire alarm i hear you giving me
better late than never let me make sure
this is a real fire and not just a drill
energy
i love it that's so fun though because
obviously you got to come up with ideas
you know you guys do so much
each season for this show and i heard
there's over 40 guests stars this season
that is so insane now you tweeted that
you were having a pinch me moment with
david allen grier and wanda sykes i mean
what was it like working with those
comedic legends oh my gosh two legends
on set and i'm not one who's normally
nervous on set but you're like david
allegree or wanda sykes are here i want
to do good and wanda is so i mean she
had played a character that was like so
funny she's like roasting robin the
whole time and i we're like genuinely
laughing on set and every take she
improvises another funny thing and
you're just watching like this is how
it's done
give it a like and put it on me
i imagine that you get the crew laughing
each sketch how do you guys make it
through a take uh we do we do make it
through our tapes but it is always my
goal to like try to break the career
i'll try to break the camera man
specifically because if they laugh it
ruins the take and that's funny to me
so
that's so good i love it so i want to
know what are your fave sketches though
because robin told us some of her
favorites are when all the women are
together all four of you yeah when the
four of us are together and again in a
season three we've been playing together
for so long that we just know how to
play off of each other like in the first
episode there's a run where i tease
robin for not wearing lotion you know
what kind of sock i have no socks okay
you don't have any lotion on either but
because it's white it's an art and stain
present too but how much of it is improv
versus say you know scripted it's all
scripted but we usually do at least one
or two like fully scripted takes and
then we just play and go crazy actually
in the trailer and see if you can spot
it they're in the trailer there's a shot
where i'm laughing like i'm holding it
together and like trying to act but if
you know me you know that i was laughing
what ends do you have to make me baby
you live in a cave yeah don't act like
you've never slept with some men's to
pay your gay friend why would you pay
for something that god just gave you
y'all are so funny everybody's so funny
and then when the guest starts come in
it's like a brand new person to come in
for one day and play and it's just like
such a delight to see i love that you
guys are bringing people into the
sandbox you guys are having such a good
time you know obviously in season one
quinta brunson was on there you were
just at the abbott elementary finale
screening what's it like to see her have
this moment right now i mean as an actor
i 100 knew that she was just like one of
the most winning lovable performers but
getting to see her as a boss and how she
takes care of her cast and her crew is
just like watching your i could say
little sister i think she's like a year
younger than me but like
watching your little sister just like
step into her power it's so cool to see
because also it's like no you never know
what the reaction is going to be like to
a show but to have critics and fans be
like this is the one yes and immediately
usually it takes shows a minute to hit
but from episode one the audience just
fell in love with them i think it's
because the show is so real and so
authentic and i love i tweet about it so
much people are like congrats on the
pickup i'm like oh i don't work on that
show
i'm just a fan
what do you got to do to get you on the
show for next season though as like a
guest spot i got a text question
right now this is a classroom not a
hoagie stand
boom hoagie
we had it on the
board
okay kids let us move on to old head one
word
young bulls are so disrespectful
well listen you're a part of so many
other amazing projects i mean no big
deal but you were the only new hire in
the writers room for ted lasso right for
this uh next season um what what what's
the line that you're super proud of
writing from that show oh and the first
episode of season two
uh ted says there's two buttons i try
never to hit that's panic and snooze
that was the first joke that i got on
the show well marcus there's two buttons
i never like to hit all right and that's
panic and snooze
come on what's it like in that room it's
the best it's so it's just as kind and
loving as you would expect from watching
the show and we were riding season two
at the like height of covid locked down
in our houses so it was so nice to get
on zoom with those people every day well
bippity-bopped
you know
i love it i have to ask you because you
have the inside knowledge or maybe maybe
do you think jason is duping us about
the there only being three seasons of
ted lasso oh i mean only jason can
answer that question okay but would you
want to see it keep going though i mean
i mean of course we all love it so much
but also what i appreciate so much about
jason is he has an artistic vision and
he's only going to do what fits that
vision so
i mean we could tweet at him all we want
have to trust the process yeah
you wrote a sam-centric episode in
season two if the show were to end do
you want rebecca and sam to maybe end up
together
oh i don't know about end up together
but i want to see as much of them
together i mean those are two very hot
actors and i sometimes write like i'm
playing with barbies i'm like who should
kiss it
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no never never again sam
i mean it
you're like let's uh let me that we're
gonna do it now yeah i love it i love it
uh you know obviously you're part of
such acclaimed shows and that means you
got to go to so many award shows this
season your fierce fashion by the way it
was so sick is there a designer you are
hoping to work with next like who like
put it out there who would you want to
work with and collaborate with on a look
oh um that's a really good question i
just hosted the wga awards and melissa
mercedes who's an la based designer here
made me an amazing dress for that with
the giant black bow i looked like a
present and i loved it um so yeah i love
getting to collaborate and like not just
go out and buy a dress but get to
actually have that collaboration is
still fun can i tell you one of my
favorites was what you wore to the emmys
it was the hot pink with the orange cape
oh yeah my superhero yeah i loved it i
loved it thank you no you were a writer
and a correspondent on full frontal
samantha b uh i actually won unm are you
correct yes i look congratulations uh
would you want to maybe one day replace
like a late night talk show host i could
see you like doing a cold bear one day
is that something you'd be interested in
maybe a guest spot but those jobs are so
hard when i worked on that show i used
to get up at 6 00 a.m and turn on the
news and not turn it off until midnight
so i am much happier playing barbies
with
yes it said lasso that's a shake i want
to write for
jesus that's what i want to do well you
are so brilliant on a black lady sketch
show i'm so excited season three only
began you guys so make sure you check
her out and them on hbo thanks for being
here thank you
you